من الله جن من النار اللهم جن من النار
اللهم جن الله من الله من اللهم اجر اللهم
اج من النار اللهم انيك
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله اما بعد يقول
الحافظ النووي رحمه الله في الباب في
الحديث التاسع عشر من رياضه في باب التوبه
في سياق حديثه الطويل عن صفوان بن عسال
عند الترمذي رضي الله تعالى عنه
يقول
قال كان يامرنا اي النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم اذا كنا سفرا او مسافرين
الا ننزع خفافنا ثلاثه ايام ولا ياليهن
الا من جنابه لكن يعني لكن يامرنا بالمسح
عليهما
من غائط وبول ونوم
فقلت هل سمعته يذكر في الهوى شيئا
الهوى هنا بمعنى الحب
ي يقال هوى ويهوى وهو بمعنى احب
فالمقصود به هنا هل سمعته يذكر اي هل سمعت
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يذكر في المحبه
شيئا يعني من الاحكام
الحكم الشرعي
في المحبه
اذا احب الانسان قوما فما حكم هذا الحب؟
قال نعم
كنا مع مع رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
في سفر
فبين نحن عنده
اذ ناداه اعرابي بصوت له جهوري
جهوري يعني صوت
عالي
يا محمد فاجابه رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم نحوا من صوته
هاؤوا
هاؤوا بمعنى اقبلوا او خذوا
والمقصود به ان الرجل كان بعيدا فناداه يا
محمد فاجابه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هاؤ
اموا يعني تعالوا
قرب
صفوان بن عال زرن حبيش askصفوان عال
صلى الله عليه وسلم
love by love
انء
صفوان
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
م
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
ها بمعنى
فقلت له ويحك
اغضض من صوتك فانك عند النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم وقد نهيت عن هذا
نهيت عن رفع الصوت واللغط عند النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
واما مخاطبته
ب باسمه فهذا لا يجوز شرعا
لكن قد يكون هذا قبل اييه قبل هذا الحكم
لا تجعلوا دعاء الرسول بينكم كدعاء بعضكم
بعضا
فهذه
الايات
انزلت من سوره النور فبها كان الانسان
يدعوه ابا القاسم يا رسول الله يا نبي
الله الى اخره لا يجوز مخاطبته باسمه
احتراما وتوقيرا وتعزيرا وتعظيما له
ولا يجوز رفع الصوت فقلت له ويحك اغضض من
صوتك فانك عند النبي وقد نهيت عن هذا
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
فقال والله لا اغض
‏said to me I will not lower my and what
ison this
he is a bed man bed man this articulates
when the companions describe
a beduin man came or beduin means that
he lives out in the
in the desert he often
‏little
customs are radically different
are more
and educated and those who are with the
prophet
in their
level of etc and manners
رضي الله عنهم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
of
very
and
they have
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم المرء يحب القوم ولما
يلحق بهم يعني بالعمل هو يحب قوما لكن لا
يعمل بعملهم ولا يدركهم في الفضائل
والمنزله
ما حكمه؟ قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
المرء
مع من احب يوم القيامه
people
was unable to upan
person what is here
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏however is not as them is not as
consistent in his worship of Allah he is
not as
he is not as
well
observing of theigion
and of the worship ofانه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
المرء مع من احب يوم القيامه
‏as no not as however a person is in
some
ز فمازال يحدثنا
حتى ذكر بابا من المغرب مسيره عرضه او
يسير الراكب في عرضه 40 او 70 عاما
الراجح هذا كله شك من الراوي عند الترمذي
عند النسائي وابن ماجه 70 عاما
هذا الباب الذي مسيره
عرضه
70 عاما يرحمك الله 70 عاما يسير الراكب
في عرضه 70 عاما هو باب التوبه
قال سفيان سفيان هنا سفيان بن عيينه احد
الرواه قبل الشام يعني في المغرب هذا
الباب قبل الشام يعني جهه الشام
جهه الشام بمعنى المغرب منهم خلقه الله
تعالى يوم خلق السماوات والارض
مفتوحا للتوبه
لا يغلق حتى تطلع الشمس منه
صفوان بن عسال
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏said man is with those he loves on the
day of resurrection and heed to mention
and mention things regarding the mercy
and forgiveness of Allah and ways that a
person can try to better himself to make
himself suitable to be with those whom
he loves on the day of judg
‏a
dire
this door that he speaking about is the
door of repentance the door of
repentance those who repent they turn to
and repentance go through this door to
سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
other
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏on
the heavens and
it will not be
closed he created it and kep it
permanently open for repentance it will
never be closed until the sun rises from
that direction until the sun rises from
the west when the sun rises from the
west ‏And that major sign of the day of
judgment is is there and the people see
the sun rise from the west then that
door of repentance will be closed as
mentions in the closing verses of
chapter number this narration was by and
graded acceptable and by him والله
وسلم
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين